our first speaker this morning is making
his second appearance at a Hillsdale
College event he's an expert on war and
foreign policy and were delighted he
could speak for us again mark Moyer is a
visiting scholar at the foreign policy
initiative the recipient of a PhD from
Cambridge University dr. Moyer
previously served as a professor at the
US Marine Corps University and as a
senior fellow at the Joint Special
Operations University in recent years he
has worked as a consultant for the
Special Operations Joint Task Force
Afghanistan US Special Operations
Command and US Central Command he's a
frequent contributor to The Wall Street
Journal and he's the author of several
books one is triumph forsaken the
Vietnam War 1954 to 1965 and another is
strategic failure how President Obama's
drone warfare defense cuts and military
amateurism have imperiled America mark
tell us what you really think
he had marquette just published
strategic failure last year when we
invited him to speak and he'll be
drawing on themes from that book this
morning his topic is American foreign
policy what is wrong and how to fix it
please welcome mark Moyer to move these
microphones downwards if I had more time
I would talk about how our speaker from
last night our friend from Milwaukee and
mr. Casper possess what in the
university is known as vertical
privilege and how students should be
required to attend sessions to to
deconstruct that privilege so it's a
pleasure it's pleasure and honor to be
here at Hillsdale today as of today I've
actually attended more Hillsdale events
than events in my my own alma mater
which is at least part of in part a
matter of choice that you feel more at
home in an institution that recite the
Pledge of Allegiance before dinner than
one that greets students had dinner with
what it calls placemats for social
justice so thank you dr. Oren and Doug
Jeffrey Tim Casper Matt bell and the
rest of the great Hillsdale team for
including me in this great gathering
here the last time I set foot in
Afghanistan was in the summer of two
thousand thirteen which was during the
drawdown of US forces that President
Obama had ordered over the objections of
his senior military commanders the
generals like just about everyone else
in the US military had believed that the
Afghan security forces were not ready to
continue the war without large numbers
of American troops to provide combat
advisers and air support President Obama
dismissed that view at times going so
far as to say that the large US military
footprint was counterproductive because
it put a strain on Afghanistan so during
a month of traveling across
Afghanistan's alluvial river valleys and
snow-capped mountains I had the
opportunity to speak with Africa
and government officials police chiefs
and military officers that's sitting on
rugged carpets that conversed with
toothless Afghan village elders who
often surprise me with their detailed
knowledge of the thralls of American
military vehicles and equipment and
American base closures when I asked them
about the impact of the American
withdrawals nearly all of the Afghans
said that the American departure was
going to spell disaster for Afghanistan
the American withdrawals as they
explained we're going to open the door
to the Taliban by weakening the Afghan
security forces and by showing the
Afghans that the United States was
abandoning them and even the bravest and
most renowned commanders and the Afghan
army and police acknowledged that this
rapid American drawdown was going to put
the government's existence in jeopardy
and then in the nearly nearly three
years that have since passed those
Afghan fears have unfortunately been
realized having been deprived of
Americans support the Afghan security
forces have sustained crippling losses
in lost control over large areas of the
country that had been purchased in years
past a great cost in American and Afghan
blood on Ted Taliban flags are now
flying within three miles of Lashkar Gah
which is one of the most important
cities in Afghanistan last month the
outgoing US commander General John
Campbell recommended loosening
restrictions on American air support in
combat advising in order to halt the
momentum of the insurgents with
President Obama who as you may recall
once won his first presidential election
by promising to ramp up what he called
the good war in Afghanistan ignore
general Campbell's recommendation this
downward spiral in Afghanistan is I
think in a lot of respects a microcosm
of American foreign policy in the age of
obama and for afghanistan is for the
rest of the world's countries the
pivotal year was 2011 that was the year
that President Obama cast off the
politically driven preach
is of a robust foreign policy and began
a broad military retreat during 2011 or
obama articulated a new strategy called
for bringing American troops home and
downsizing the armed forces which was a
strategy design motivated by a desire to
downsize the military and cut defense
spending in order to spare domestic
programs from budget cuts so in this
spirit Obama pulled American forces out
of Iraq in late 2011 again over the
objections of the generals and this as I
go into a lot of depth and strategic
failure this really destroyed the
sectarian accommodation in Iraq and
paved the way for the rise of Isis the
Obama administration vowed to pivot to
Asia but its budget cuts prevented the
promised transfers of air naval assets
to the Pacific as a result of that
America's military standing in the Far
East sank and that caused the the region
smaller countries to bend to the will of
the Chinese to compensate for this
contraction of the military Obama
intensified surgical strikes against
Allah Islamic extremists through drones
and Special Operations raids the
administration advocates of the war by
surgical strike of whom Vice President
Biden was the loudest claimed that the
strikes would keep the lid on terrorist
organizations at a very low price now
we've seen over time that the drone
strikes and Special Operations raids
have killed hundreds of terrorists but
they haven't crippled terrorist
organizations or prevented them from
taking from attack in the United States
or deprive them of sanctuary and on
Obama's watch al Qaeda and Isis have
gained sanctuaries in Syria Iraq
Afghanistan Pakistan Yemen Libya and
Molly giving them more square miles of
sanctuary than they possessed on
September 11 2001 and continue a
Democratic Party tradition that dates
back to george mcgovern's ill-fated
candidacy in 1972
Obama has adhered to the principle the
United States does not need to assert
itself militarily to maintain its
credibility as a superpower his
unwillingness to deploy employ military
force has however I think inflicted
severe damage to America's credit
credibility and further undermining
America's credibility is the was the
issuance of threats that Obama has
failed to see through and most most
notorious of these empty threats was the
so-called red line on Syria's chemical
weapons so when the Syrian government
crossed that red line Obama did not
attempt to enforce it but instead made
the preposterous claim that he had not
even set the red line but rather it had
been set by the international community
in the US Congress and we now know that
Obama's hesitation decembe lling and in
action during this whole red line affair
caused great worry among our traditional
allies from Japan and South Korea to
Saudi Arabia and Israel leading them to
the worry that the United States would
not come to their aid in a time of
crisis and our adversaries capitalized
on its loss of credibility to undertake
new provocations Russia sees the Crimea
six months later without anything more
than a few will protest from the White
House despite the fact that the United
States had a pledge dating back to the
Clinton administration that we would
protect Ukraine from external aggression
Iran's confidence in our weakness as a
result of the red line convinced Iran's
leaders to drive a hard bargain in the
nuclear negotiations that culminated in
the joint comprehensive plan of action
in 2015 another characteristic of
Obama's foreign policy that harks back
to the age of McGovern is the
downplaying of external threats during
the 2012 election you may remember Obama
mocked written Mitt Romney for warning
of the threat posed by Russia in one of
the presidential debates Obama scoffed
the 1980s they're now calling to ask for
their foreign policy back because you
know the call
war's been over for 20 years Obama
derided Isis as the JV team shortly
before Isis swept across Syria in Iraq
and last month he downplayed the threat
of terrorism by remarking that more
Americans die from falling in bathtubs
than from terrorist attacks in the 1980s
I would argue our deed back when in a
different sense than what Obama was
talking about we are now in the nineteen
eighty of the Obama presidency with the
president who's forced to combat threats
that priory inattention had permitted to
metastasize just has happened at the end
of the Carter presidency so Obama now
finds himself scrambling to contain the
damage wrought by his weak policies in
Iraq Syria Afghanistan Libya Eastern
Europe and South China Sea among other
places mom and sent five thousand troops
back to Iraq to deal with Isis and he's
cancelled his plans to withdraw all
american forces from afghanistan by the
end of his presidency he just ordered an
armored Brigade back into europe to
defend nato allies from russian
aggression these are half measures only
their intended to invert complete ruin
before the end of Obama's term I think
rather than to pull the United States
out of the deep holes into which we have
been dug and getting out of those holes
well now I think be long and arduous
even if his successor acts more
vigorously in astutely which I think at
this point is far from certain as far as
his latest instance of minimizing
threats the the so-called bathtub
comment I think the president is also on
shaky ground if you look Islamic
extremists have killed much larger
number of Westerners under the Obama
administration than in the last seven
years of the Bush administration and
that teller would be much higher were
not for the fortuitous failure of
detonators in the underwear bomb plot
and the times square plot the allegation
that America is overly concerned with
terrorism also misses the point that the
number of the fatalities is relatively
low because of the massive expenditures
that we have spent on combating
terrorism both in the United States and
abroad
and their camp there can be no doubt
that without these expenditures the
number of Islamic extremist attacks
would have been far higher this
administration like prior Democratic
administrations has been more eager to
apply military force to humanitarian
problems than to security problems in
Libya and 2011 as in much like in Somali
in 1993 the White House venture to
achieve humanitarian objectives by
imposing a new political order through
force the United States and its NATO
allies toppled the Gaddafi regime by
supporting Libyan rebels and did so
without the use of NATO ground forces
which led Secretary of State Hillary
Clinton to trumpet it as a triumph of
smart power for those who are unfamiliar
with the self-congratulatory jargon of
the political establishment the term
smart power refers to power that is
primarily non-military in nature but as
we know things didn't turn out quite so
well in Libya that absence of us and
nato ground forces allowed islamic
extremists to escape from Libya's jail
led to the killing of the US ambassador
of Benghazi and the breakdown of central
governance in in Libya another
manifestation of smart power the Obama
administration used diplomatic clout to
oust autocratic leaders in the name of
promoting democracy the results were
similarly similarly catastrophic Obama
forced out Egyptian dictator Hosni
Mubarak only to have him replaced at the
ballot box by Mohamed Morsi of the
Muslim Brotherhood and more seized power
grabs and his repressive tactics
precipitated a military coup which the
Obama administration reluctantly had to
accept the case of Yemen Obama al stood
Yemeni strong man Ali Abdullah Saleh
which in turn allowed the Houthi
militants to devour the fledgling
democracy and overrun the country
another similarity with its Democratic
forbearers
the Obama administration is used
development aid as an alternative to
military power then countries such as
Yemen Pakistan and Molly sought to spend
aid in areas that were under the
influence of extremist groups and the
belief that alleviating poverty and
ignorance would erode the appeal of the
extremists this approach has failed
repeatedly and it great cost to American
taxpayers and largely because the aid
groups were not actually able to or
willing to get the protection of
security forces and so the extremist
intimidated or killed the eight workers
destroyed their projects and forced the
aid agencies to withdraw the
administration's foreign assistance
programs I would argue have suffered
from a number of other conceptual errors
by focusing almost entirely on poverty
the administration has failed to address
the problems of ineffectual and corrupt
governance which in my view are the root
cause of the dysfunction we see in the
third world USAID Agency for
International Development has reduced
spending for programs that are focused
on leadership and governance and instead
spent more on sectors of less lasting
impact the last and least forgivable
problem of the nation's current foreign
policy is the intrusion of politics into
policy and most presidents have at some
time or another given in to the
temptation to let considerations of
personal popularity partisan competition
domestic legislative ambitions influence
their foreign policy but I would argue
that Democratic presidents have yielded
more often to this temptation going back
at least to Lyndon Johnson and I think
Barack Obama has yielded more than any
of his fellow Democrats so the Afghan
escalation of 2009 the drawdowns in
Afghanistan and Iraq the firing of
General Stanley McChrystal the Benghazi
debacle are just a few of the examples
we see in this presidency of politics
taking precedence over the national
interest so what can be done to fix u.s.
foreign policy
well to begin with the United States
needs to articulate and implement a
coherent global strategy which is
something that it hasn't done under this
administration and if you pursue a
coherent strategy it will actually make
possible and active foreign policy where
we are taking the lead rather than a
reactive foreign policy of the type we
have seen since 2009 but increasing our
military power and increasing its use we
can restore our credibility and in our
global global leadership role I think
the next administration will have to
increase the number of American ground
troops in the Middle East and the
greater Middle East in order to combat
the spread of Islamic terrorism and
sectarianism and we'll also have to add
troops to Eastern Europe to deter
further Russian aggression will need to
put additional air in naval forces in
the Pacific to discourage our allies in
the region from couch howling to the
Chinese and in the Western Hemisphere to
impede the flow of illicit narcotics
these commitments together with the need
to rejuvenate and maintain our armed
forces will require an increase in
defense spending I think ideally to at
least four percent of GDP which will
reverse a downward trend that we've been
on towards three percent and that four
percent number is actually quite low in
historical terms and certainly will not
break the national bank which is not
true of the entitlement programs that
have continued to grow during President
Obama's tenure so building a critical
mass of support for a larger bolder
national defense will I think require a
Republican president who can bring
together the political right as Ronald
Reagan did in the 1980s you know the
Iraq war opened fissures between
neoconservatives paleo conservatives
libertarians and other factions on the
political right many of those have yet
to close but rather than relitigate
invasion of rat of Iraq which some
members of these groups continue to do I
think it would be more productive to
focus on it on a foreign policy agenda
that has broad appeal across the
right and it's not in my view is overly
difficult task because there are
numerous areas of agreement say most on
the right recognize the virtues of
maintaining a strong military
conservatives are generally attuned to
international threats and are suspicious
enough of human nature to doubt that
peace can be kept simply through
diplomatic goodwill and United Nations
resolutions most on the right also
recognize that maintaining critic
credibility is crucial for a superpower
and that maintaining credibility
requires the use of force on occasion
now at present there is a small but
vocal element of self-described paleo
conservatives who argue that that most
foreign interventions are futile and
wasteful and we should avoid them and
they purport to uphold the traditions of
paleo conservative icons including the
most esteemed of those icons Edmund
Burke and Russell Kirk but I think this
is a false reading of paleo conservatism
the great pelo conservative thinkers
recognize in fact the need to intervene
abroad against threats that jeopardized
our national interest or civilization
itself during the French Revolution
Edmund Burke actually advocated foreign
intervention to put down the
revolutionaries who me called a college
of armed fanatics for the propagation of
the principles of assassination robbery
rebellion fraud faction oppression and
impiety I during the 1960's Russell Kirk
thought the United States needed more
rather than less intervention in Vietnam
during the 1960's recommending that the
United States shift from its defensive
strategy in South Vietnam to an
offensive strategy against North Vietnam
opposite from the isolationists on the
spectrum of right-wing foreign policy
are those who advocate military
intervention as a remedy to nearly every
threat on the interventionist our door
has certainly been weakened by events in
in Iraq and Afghanistan but it's not
entirely disappeared I think the extreme
interventionist is also as problematic
as extreme isolation ism
both of them are flawed by a
one-size-fits-all approach to situations
that demand a prudent consideration of
the circumstances and so I think we need
to to rein in our overzealousness and
interventionism by reminding ourselves
of the histories of war which would show
that the human and material cost of war
often greatly exceed what was originally
forecast and that the outcomes often
fall short of expectations I think a
large number of Americans can be rallied
around the idea that the death of a
single American at the hands of a
terrorist is an intolerable affront to
the nation I think most Americans
understand what President Obama seems to
miss which is that getting blown up at
the Boston Marathon or or getting shot
in Paris is altogether different from
dying in a bathtub or a car crash
Americans don't tolerate the murder of
one of their citizens in a carjacking or
a home invasion in order in order we try
to minimize the significance of those
events and I think protecting our
citizens is a matter of national honor
and it's also a matter of deterrence
because our enemies are going to be less
inclined to harm Americans if they see
harsh retribution meted out to those who
have committed an offense President
Obama does understand at some level the
importance of a single killing and I say
that based on the strong personal
interest he's shown in cases where the
individuals were were killed under
circumstances of relevance to his pet
issues and we heard for those who were
here last night we heard it good great
commentary on this but if you look at
you know the killing of Trayvon Martin
by a private citizen during a street
scuffle with the shooting of Michael
Brown by a police officer who Brown had
assaulted after committing a burglary
elicited outrage from Obama we heard no
comparisons from Obama about bathtub
fatalities versus those killed in by
police officer but rather a call for
justice and the president was willing to
leave no stone unturned and no dollar
unspent to investigate the suspects and
implement preventive measures in the
cases of men who who in his words
look like they could have been his sons
the shooters in these incidents both
were acquitted seems not to have changed
the president's tendency to view
gun-toting american citizens and
American police officers is more
worrisome than international terrorists
the Obama administration's preoccupation
with non-military power has resulted in
a lot of failures there are a lot of
things we can do I think with with
non-military power as well as military
power we can regain confidence of our
allies with the diplomacy of a president
who is it once more congenial and more
firm and standing up for our nation and
for its allies and I think rebuilding
our military and our credibility will do
great things for our diplomacy foreign
assistance can be made much more
effective than it currently is and I
recently published a book on the subject
so I'll talk a little bit about this for
one thing I think in terms of foreign
assistance we need to shift from poverty
alleviation to the cultivation of
foreign leaders as those leaders are the
people who ultimately are going to fix
the problems of governance that leave
the third world in a perpetual state of
dependence on outside support the
behavior of those leaders depends
heavily on the on their culture with
foreign donors as such can influence
cultural values in in these countries
when people are fairly young in their
teens or 20s when individuals are in
their 40s or 50s which is when they're
actually holding positions of power they
are largely immune to cultural influence
so our enduring foreign assistance
requires a long-term approach as opposed
to the current approach which is focused
on a short-term achievement of numerical
poverty reduction targets the most
effective way to affect cultural changes
to occupy a country for decades and
force its people to accept new cultural
norms that was a model that Norman's
used in England and that's what we did
in Germany in Japan after World War two
the United States seldom has an appetite
for
or commitments of that size or duration
but it does have another means of
affecting cultural change and that is by
the education of foreign elites either
at foreign universities that we support
or at American universities and the US
government actually used to do a lot of
this we funded a lot of higher education
in the early cold war but then pulled
out of in the 1970s because of a rise in
anti Lee sentiment among America's
liberal intelligentsia so I think it's
time to go back to that model of the
early cold war which was very important
in transforming countries like South
Korea and Taiwan chile and colombia and
that will mean increasing our assistance
to foreign universities in terms of
funding curriculum and student
organization it also means increasing
the number of civic-minded foreign
youths whom we bring to the united
states for higher education scholarships
yet to reap the benefit of those
scholarships what we need to do is make
sure those students are actually tasting
taking courses in Western civilization
and American history and as you know all
too well those subjects have been
marginalized or removed at most American
universities the United States I think
can and should continue to support
democracy abroad but in a different way
from both the Bush and Obama
administrations for whom it has largely
been counterproductive history shows
that that liberal democracy does
outperform autocracy in terms of
promoting peace stability and economic
development but history also shows that
a start-up democracy has a high risk of
turning into a tyranny oftentimes one
that's more violent and repressive than
the original regime democracy was made
possible in ancient Greece and Rome and
then in the modern West by cultural
values that are specific to Western
civilization Western individualism and
Western law facilitated restrictions on
governmental power Western pluralism
kept individuals from taking up arms
against democratic governments that they
disliked
the Western sense of civic virtue led
citizens to serve in the government
without using their office to selfish
ends America's founding fathers believed
that the success of their democratic
experiment depended on these cultural
attributes and I think they were right
of the countries that have since tried
liberal democracy only those with
conducive cultures have been able to
succeed so turning traditionally
authoritarian countries into virtuous
democracies therefore requires cultural
change as well and in the nations where
the 50 year olds are not imbued with
cultural values that are consistent with
democracy setting the cultural
conditions for democracy is likely to
take several decades and if we attempt
to transform such countries into
democracies more quickly likely to end
up as unhappily as it did in Libya Egypt
and Yemen finally a better foreign
policy requires the excision of
self-interested politics from foreign
policy our founding fathers made clear
the need for political leaders who set
aside their private interests in the
pursuit of the public interest James
Madison wrote in Federalist 57 that the
aim of every political Constitution is
or ought to be first to obtain for
rulers men who possess most wisdom to
discern and most verse you to pursue the
common good of society and in the next
place to take the most effectual
precautions for keeping them virtuous
whilst they continue to hold their
public trust it's thus incumbent of on
those of you who are voting whether in
today's presidential primary here in New
York or future presidential contests to
gauge which candidate would be least
likely as president to spend American
dollars or endanger American troops for
the benefit of their poll numbers the
American people their elected
representatives in Congress and the
media must remain vigilant and hold the
President to account for such corruption
no less than it would for the theft of
funds from the pub
coffers thank you very much
we have time for some questions so if
you want to just raise your hand no
walking around I'm bill Gaffney and
recently within the last few days and
about two months ago we had a ship that
was buzzed by several MiG's and came
very close we could pick them up on
radar on the ship a couple hundred miles
out two months ago approximately about
16 sailors were captured on a gunboat
that much outperformed the gunboat that
took them and they were held kind of
prisoners in Iran how far up the chain
of command do you think the skipper of
the ship in the and the gunboats got
their instructions not to fire that's a
good question and I I do not know the
answer that's a question those are
questions a lot of people are asking I
think the both of those incidents bring
us back again to this question of
credibility I don't think you would have
seen Iran or Russia doing those sorts of
things with with the President Reagan
but it's become so clear that that this
administration will do anything possible
to avoid a conflict that that they're
willing to keep pushing and pushing and
we've seen that certainly with Putin's
got a history of doing that which is why
you know we're finally seeing this this
movement of forces in eastern europe the
Baltic States continue to be an area of
great grave concern because we've given
Putin every reason to believe that we
are not going to go to war over the
Baltic states yet those are NATO member
states and so if they're invaded either
we are in war with Russia or the NATO
alliance falls apart but but clearly the
the Iranian one is a particularly
interesting issue because as you
mentioned we have it appears that there
was no need for them to surrender and
that also most people that I talked to
in the Navy think that
that they should have put up armed
resistance under those circumstances
rather than simply surrender but yet
exactly how that came to pass I think we
still need to get to the bottom of that
thanks
like I think there's a microphone back
thank you um I'm sorry sir we'll bring
it by throwing up to use exercise my
name is Alice LaBrie and I'm former US
Department of State Foreign Service
principally serving in the Middle East
I'd like your comments on two things
first of all I am very wary about the
deal with Cuba and number two I don't
believe in treaties because I don't
trust the other guy ever so I'd like
your comments on this yes well they deal
with Cuba you know I think this is
another example where I mean we're
seeing this president certainly becoming
more and more concerned with his legacy
and I think he's willing to do symbolic
things and even things that run contrary
to our interests in order to have things
that he can hold up as accomplishments I
think the Iran deal is a particularly
bad example that were he caved in on a
lot of things simply so he could portray
himself as the one who achieved some
kind of deal with Iran and by the time
it all falls apart he's going to be out
of office and then someone else can take
the blame for that Cuba thing you know
the idea that relaxing really relaxing
tensions with Cuba and allowing greater
commerce is going to fix things I don't
think that's it's not particularly
plausible the opportunities for our
businesses to go in there actually
pretty small and owing to the the state
control of the economy if you look at
Vietnam which country I know quite well
you heard the same things about going to
Vietnam and trade with them and bring
our ideas and they're going to
liberalize and 20 years of that still
haven't borne fruit so I think yeah I
think we're not going to get as much out
of at least in the near term as we
thought as far as treaties the we do
have a problem we have number of
problems with treaties and you know
trees you know Sarah seldom hold up when
there aren't either interests or force
that are actually their underlying there
to preserve them we also have a great
problem in this country I think in terms
of the turnover on political parties and
and in my own view is that the countries
generally have greater faith in our
credibility when we've had strong
defense Foreign Paul presidents in power
which is since you know since Kennedy
has basically met the Republicans and so
it's very hard to maintain the lasting
commitments of that sort we do and we
find out you know the Ukraine cases is
an exempt excellent example the problems
we've had you know we in 1994 we
convinced the Ukrainians to give up
their nuclear weapons because we said we
were going to protect them and and this
is also a good example you this
president talked a lot about how great
disarmament is what you look at the
Ukrainians they gave up their weapons
and what happened to them they got
invaded so and then President Obama you
found in a way I mean it's very easy it
can be very easy to find ways out of all
these treaty commitments and he
certainly did that in that case so so
yes I think we need to be skeptical of
treaties that are simply based on a
piece of paper they have there have to
be underlying interests and and force in
place that will actually ensure that
those those will take place in the case
of Iran to we're already seeing
violations of that treating
yes thank you for your talk I think you
left one element I would like you to
comment on the underlying driving force
that these particular people possess one
power control etc the usual features is
religion they're using the religion to
achieve their ends the religion of my
view was set up as a religion of war and
conquest if we notice something at a
reformation getting that to change there
are a few moderates not many all I see
is containment from what you said yes
with it that's an excellent excellent
question and I have written about that
in some other context I do think you
know there are certainly strains in much
of the Islamic world as opposed to Isis
and al-qaeda much as we are but we've
done a poor job of actually enlisting
their help in a lot of cases that's part
of why I think it makes sense to support
education one of the things we see with
a lot of extremists is they have a very
caricatured view of the west and if you
look at their educational backgrounds
almost all of them are engineers or
scientists and there's been a fair
amount written about this but you know
those people tended for one thing they
look at things in very black-and-white
terms but also they have just not been
you know exposed to you know a
thoughtful description of what the West
is about and this is again a problem
with our exchange programs you know we
bring people here and we've seen a fair
amount of extremists who have come over
here again most of them studies science
and math and if you go to most
universities today you don't have to
take Western civilization or American
history as you as you once had to and so
something we can't change everybody that
way but but we have to do a lot better
job of explaining what we are is that
even you know a lot of Americans say
they don't really know what it is we
really stand for the principles that
that that we are based upon
I will say you know one thing that we
don't consider enough about Islam too is
that it does have much higher barriers
to new ideas than really any anyplace
else you'll the world you know that's
partly why if you look at East Asia
we've been able to liberalize countries
they're much more quickly because you
don't have a religion there that you
know is automatically hostile to to
foreign ideas and foreign religions and
so it is a bigger challenge I do think
you know we need to we do need to think
about ways to improve our relations with
much of the Islamic world I think Europe
has a much more difficult problem than
we do because they have much larger
Islamic population there and they're
they're really wrestling with that issue
especially can they've also got you know
much higher birth rates among the Muslim
population and I think they do have they
really have to reconsider their
immigration policies and they're
starting to think through that but you
know I think it when a group becomes big
enough in that context it does become a
threat and we are not in that position
but but we do need to do more again I
think this administration if you look at
its really alienated many of our our
Islamic allies in a number in a number
of different ways so so that I think for
that hopefully we can get an
administration that will will be able to
get back to this also gets in the
question of democracy to because we have
a lot of the people who are have been
our allies in the Muslim world are not
Democrats and we've thrown them out you
know people like Mubarak and so I think
we're we need to recognize that we can't
simply believe we're going to
democratize this place and yet at the
same time not destabilize it so this way
so we need to think of gradual change in
these places and starting with the
younger generation rather than trying to
to to change these people's minds
overnight
is VAR c on the basis of your just as a
guest on the basis of your research and
contact give them the continuing failure
of the foreign policy to be attributable
mostly to stupid incompetent or evil
intent or equal parts of both
approximately yeah that's an excellent
question that's a and I've had number
debates with my colleagues over those
questions and one thing I will say the
preface is that our views on this are
going to evolve a bit over time I mean
as so many spend all the time it on
history a lot of important information
won't come out for decades later but I
think we have enough information to to
have a rough sense of it you know I see
there's sort of three three factors at
work here well before they're so you
have the stupid and competence is
certainly one factor the question of
political self-interest and doing things
that are politically beneficial to the
president is another the third you have
is groovey a naivete about how the world
works and in thinking you know there for
example we give people money they will
like us and then the fourth is the more
you know I guess sinister V part which
is you know supporting sort of radical
you know movement so we do see you know
evidence that this administration has an
affinity for for you know left-wing
dictators in a variety of places so i
think it's it's all of those it's
changed over time you know the first
couple years was really more politically
focused you saw obama increasing the
number of troops in afghanistan because
an increase in the drone strikes because
he wanted to kind of show he was tough
but from 2011 that that part of politics
is received it'll then we now see the
part of just trying to make him provide
some kind of legacy you know the in
competence i think is
been characteristic throughout and part
of that is to that this administration
is consciously ignored what the military
has had to say and then you know in the
naivete and the sort of far left
promotion of revolution there's a
certain intermixture there but I think
we've seen seen both of those so i think
really all for those factors are at work
here thank you for your talk I wonder if
you could comment on why you think we
should increase military spending
particularly with the fact that we spend
a huge amount of money wastefully in the
military as it is and also historically
if you look back before World War one
for example military spending was very
low so I wonder if you could justify why
we should increase military expand as
opposed to make better policies as you
outlined so well in your talk yeah
that's a good question in strategic
failure I'd go into this a bit now I've
spent a fair amount of time working the
Department of Defense I'll be the first
to tell you that there is waste in the
military I think there has been the only
good thing that's come out of the big
budget cuts is that there has been some
pressure to cut out wasteful spending I
also say it's remarkable how much
wasteful spending manages to survive
those sorts of cuts as well so we
certainly need to do more you know we
can there's can always be more done to
fix that but you know we've cut to the
point that we've you know we've had to
cut the army by over 100,000 troops
we've cut the marine corps with a number
of ships are going on a number of
aircraft and we're also seeing readiness
is going down if you look in the news
there's a lot of aircraft crashing
because we don't have enough to keep
them up you know the smaller size of the
force is also putting great strain on
our manpower because we keep sending the
same people back into conflict again and
again you know certainly do spend more
than other countries but but the reason
I think we need to do that and why we
need to spend more than we were you know
pre-world War two at pre-world War one
is that we are the only country that's
really capable of
of preserving sort of global order and
and we are so dependent on international
trade and commerce and there's other
reasons too i think you know Americans
we like the ability to go to other
countries to see other countries that's
I think very important for Americans to
do it helps you appreciate your own
culture you know we have missionaries
that go around the world who we'd like
to protect and so you know no other no
other country is capable of doing this I
mean if Europeans can't even now
maintain order in their backyard you
know Russia and India's can be China and
India or rising powers but they're not
going to well neither of them really
aspire to be global leaders and they're
much more concerned just about their
economic interests and they're more
focused on their own regions you know
certainly to make argument well maybe
it's time for the u.s. to pull back from
this you know that's kind of what's
happened in Europe Europeans used to be
very globally minded now they sit back
but they're dependent on on us and then
when they see things like Paris or
Brussels happen or these mass influx of
immigrants they're at a loss of what to
do so as I said I mean four percent of
GDP is actually pretty low in historical
terms we can certainly afford it if you
look at entitlement spending it's gone
from twelve to fourteen percent under
Obama and we do certainly I think we do
need to think about our long-term debt
but that's unfortunately that's you know
politicians on both sides of the aisle
have been reluctant to to touch that so
it's it's not an easy problem you know
we have in the book I talk about we go
through cycles a lot of times the United
States decides after a war that it's
going to cut the military because we're
not going to fight another war again and
that's bit us badly several times you
know after World War Two we slashed the
military from forty some percent of GDP
to three percent and then five years
later we were in the Korean War and
we're ill-prepared and a lot of people
died because the military is not
prepared we've had more farsighted
presidents who you know like Eisenhower
who was willing to maintain a military
and time of peace
and I think you know most of our wars we
end up in are not wars of our choosing
we didn't bush in want to fight it long
war in Iraq or Afghanistan but given our
position in the world I don't think we
have a choice and so I think it's it's
either we cut now and imperil the lives
of those who are going to get put in or
we spend a little bit more and we're
better prepared and by the way also by
spending more I think we help deter
adversaries because they pay a lot of
attention you know the Iranians pay a
lot of attention to what we're spending
on defense the Chinese do and they prey
on weakness
you're absolutely correct about the
downplay of Western civilization in the
universities also along with that though
is the inculcation of leftist ideas into
the schools of journalism and as a
result the Americans are not really
being exposed to the proper ideas of the
kind of foreign policy that you
correctly advocate the Free Press that
was supposed to have in my opinion isn't
that freaking and this is a big problem
we even see it now in the trying to
influence the presidential election and
so what you correctly say is exacerbated
even further by the kind of information
that the American public gets because
the American public needs to be behind
what you correctly state yeah I'd say
journalism almost as bad as academia
when in that regard the v1 good point is
that there are alternative outlets more
than there used to be because this
problems gone back after day for a long
time there was actually great
documentary on Fox News a couple weeks
ago on defense where they interviewed
gates and Panetta and Hagel one day a
lot of detail about all the terrible
things that happened to our military and
you won't see that on any of the other
networks so you know there are people
seeing this but again you know a lot of
for a lot of young people they're not
going to see the 10pm Fox documentary
they're going to learn a lot from their
University class and certainly what's a
lot of military history has gone from
the academia what's left and a lot of
the diplomatic history is certainly has
a certain biases you know and then we've
also got you know with the Millennial
Generation there's also a question about
where
they're getting their information in
general but yeah those are those are
excellent points and I think one other
point a tattoo is a lot of educating and
people comes from the the Oval Office
even the president better than anyone
else can educate the American people and
this president has almost never talks
about the wars were fighting he doesn't
say much about foreign policy and so
that again where we need a commander
chief who will actually you know educate
the American people on what they ought
to know about foreign policy my question
Admiral James ace Lyons said that Islam
is a political movement masquerading as
a religion and it uses its religious
aspects to deflect abundant criticism
that it's a totalitarian system now when
people try to point this out people like
a Pamela Geller their pilloried as being
Islamophobes and the press is not going
to pick this up but I think it's
critical that the American people
realized that Islam is a totalitarian
system do you have any ideas how this
could be accomplished thank you as well
there is you know I do think there are I
mean there's a within Islam there is a
the more extreme versions are very you
know overtly totalitarian I think there
is a real problem in this country in
terms of political correctness opposing
sort of any criticism of Islam or any
notion that Islam is associated with
terrorism and the White House is kind of
encourages view you know if you think
back to the fort hood shooting Hasan the
shooter a lot of people were concerned
about his his views but they were also
afraid that if they said something they
might be considered to be
anti-islamic we also saw that in San
Bernardino case where people didn't want
to report suspicious things because they
thought they would be accused of bigotry
and so that is a real problem you know I
do think we need to it's worth again we
can educate ourselves better on Islam I
think there certainly are different
competing parts there are certainly
organizations in this country that are
aligned with the more totalitarian
strains I think we again it's worthwhile
to try to differentiate and to work with
those and there's certainly some who are
willing to work with us on these issues
so again to your earlier point I think
we do need to avoid sort of this jumping
to conclusions that any criticism of
Islam is is is out of bounds well you
know we should also one other thing I
would just add is we need to be careful
how we say it because it can also hurt
us in foreign countries where we're
trying to rely on these Islamic
countries for help if they see us going
a little too overboard it may be
detrimental to our interest there all
right we have time for one more question
I with your experience in the Middle
East do we really have any supporters in
the Middle East considering the present
situation with Saudi Arabia as well it's
there's not a lot of love for us
anywhere I mean we've certainly
thoroughly alienated most of our former
allies and it's audis the Israelis we
still have common interests with them
but you know and there is a you know a
widespread perception is somewhat just
finally that we are kind of casting our
lot with the Iranians now the
administration denied that but but
certainly some of the things we've done
give that impression you know again part
of this gets back to credibility to you
know we used to you can criticize there
were a lot of problems with the Iraq war
but when we invaded Iraq every country
in that region was afraid of us because
they thought they might be next and so
they were we had influence with them and
if we threaten something they could now
our credibility is so low that the
countries that used to like us don't you
know the president's cut read some
comments about Saudi Arabia have you no
further jeopardized what we're doing
there in the Gulf countries in general
or you know feel like they've been sold
out especially with the Iran nuclear
deal and you know I think the
administration thinks the Iranians are
going to eventually come around to be
more friendly with us I mean conceivable
but it seems you know that I think
there's probably a lot of wishful
thinking if you go back to the 90s that
people were saying that then it rains or
more modern than the Sunnis and they're
going to start becoming more friendly to
us and so I think that whole region is
just very is deeply troubling and we've
dug ourselves in a huge hole in Syria
and Iraq it's going to be very hard for
the next administration to turn things
around i do think probably we may need
to put more troops in there's right now
our presence isn't big enough to restore
our credibility but if we you know the
United States is really the only country
I think that ultimately can try to
broker some kind of accommodation in
this sunni-shiite civil war which is
spawning insecurity and extremism and
and other problems there's no easy cure
I think the next administration when it
comes in there's going to be probably
more and more bad things happening
between now and then I think there is I
think our enemies are probably looking
at the calendar and they're thinking
they're going to try to get in as much
as they can before the next president
comes in and if you look in 1981 the end
of Carters term the Salvadoran rebels
launched an offensive
10 days before Carter took left office
because they thought that he said the
fanatic Reagan might might crack down us
so we got to win this war now
fortunately they didn't but but you know
if you look at all the circles Putin has
run around us I think things could be
even worse in the Middle East by January
of next year well thank you very much
for your attendance